vous avez tous ceux en tête vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président le chiffre
de 13 milliards de 13 milliards d'euros
d'économies que l'état vous demande de
réaliser sur sa corde mais vous l'avez
dit vous-même disons bien ce que
représentent ces 13 milliards d'euros il
ne s'agit pas de 13 milliards d'euros de
baisses de la dépense locale
nous vous demandons de maîtriser votre
dépenses y compris votre dépense
tendanciel qui est ans
c'est très différent vos dépenses vous
continuer à progresser mais vous devez
infléchir la courbe
vous devez limiter cette augmentation et
vous devez participer au désendettement
des administrations publiques au sens le
plus global
si chacun joue le jeu si chacun contient
ses dépenses de fonctionnement et réduit
son endettement
alors nous n'aurons pas besoin de
revenir à la rigidité des mécanismes
correctifs